I'm Colson. You bought 112 individual episodes of
Everybody Loves Raymond. Pete, I don't.
I don't know what to say.
Bravo.
You've caught me. We freaky Fridayed.
We freaky Fridayed.
Welcome to Miami 305.
That's the area code.
It does bother me a little bit that everybody
thinks it's my fault.
And I understand why they do.
Of course. And you can, too.
Of course. I mean, we do one update feature
together and then my life completely
changes. There's theories online that we
swap souls.
I've read all of them.
Yeah.
To the point where I was reading them, I was
like, did I did this have this f***ing
happen?
We hug at the end and that's when people say
the soul switch. Yes.
And your soul came into me and made me like
a degenerate drug addict.
Yeah. Everyone thinks we freaky Fridayed.
We freaky Fridayed.
It makes a lot of sense.
I don't personally believe in the theory,
but it's well researched and footnoted.
You believe this? My grandson thinks I need a
hooker to get laid.
I don't know.
Your kidding. Your grandpa was the Wilt
Chamberlain of Staten Island.
First of all.
Hey, if I tattooed every girl that I ever
banged on my body, I'd be f***ing memento
over here. Who's Memento?
What did you think was going to happen?
What if I fell in love with her?
Yeah. Pete, you're playing with fire, and I'm
fire.
You certainly are.
Yeah
you are.
Well, we're here. We might as well have some
fun.
I'd like to make a toast to the most handsome
gentleman in this joint.
Where are they?
I'll cheers that. Leave me a clown.
A real clown.
Honk honk. Yeah.
Hey, man, can I get a picture with you?
Hey, bartender, give me a root beer float
over here. Personal joke.
I'm glad you guys are having fun?
Because it did cost five grand for the
Sinatra suite.
So, $5,000 for a suite?
Yeah, for a hooker.
Sinatra better be in there.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God. Oh, sh*t.
Woo! Woo!
Oh, my God, bro, I feel so alive.
Take that light. Take that light.
F*** it. Oh, no.
Oh.
Well, that was a that was a close one.
Oh, my God. F***ing leave your aunt a second
if I had this thing, you know what I'd like
to do? What? Take this thing to the bridge.
Take it to the bridge.
Drive off that f***ing thing.
You know what I mean? Just f***ing see how
far out into the water we can get.
Think about that sh*t sometimes.
We'd be able to survive it in this.
It's like a boat. F*** this.
Let's go crazy. Take your seatbelt off.
Huh? Huh? Who says that?
Me. Take off your seatbelt.
Whoa.
Oh, God.
Pete. Oh, no.
Hi. It stops now.
What? I know what's going on.
What are you talking about?
Sebastian. Stan. No more talking.
Only listening. Okay. Because I'm only going
to say this once. It stops now.
Dude, you left your account logged in the
trailer. I'm a fan.
This is what happens. Of course I'm going to
use it. You bought 112 individual episodes
of Everybody Loves Raymond.
That's stupid. Why don't you just bundle it?
Why don't you f***ing stream it, for f***'s
sake. It's streaming on Peacock.
It's streaming on the cock.
You are what we call a daddy.
Such a daddy.
You're crazy. I never do this.
But do you think I'd be able to get a
selfie? Please.
Hey, that's my best friend, man.
Oh, snap.
This mother f***ing Bucky Barnes winter
soldier. Hey, I'm Cameron.
I just needed time off from my schedule, so
I told my I was addicted to nuke.
That's not even a drug.
I seen that sh*t in RoboCop two.
JT Kiss.
Eli Manning.
Quarterback, Ole Miss.
Eli.
Peet, huh?
Please. Introduce yourself to the room.
Um. Hi am Pete.
Ha, ha.
Found your ass.
Gentlemen. Hello, everybody.
Hello. Hello. Hello, my dude.
Colton, are you real?
What? Are you real?
The f*** are you talking about? Yes.
I'm real. Sorry I was having a f***ing weird
day, dude. Yeah, like this party sucks.
Let's go smoke a joint.
We're in f***ing rehab.
What is. Is.
Is rehab.
Ah, okay.
Yeah. See, Amy gave me the address, but she
did not tell me that this is where I was
going.
Hey, man, How's it going?
Hey, Ray. Hey.
Can I. Can I talk to you for a sec?
Yeah, I got a spot.
I'm going on stage.
I know. It'll only take a second.
Yeah, sure, man. What's.
What's up? What's going on?
I'm good.
Man. I just figured we should, you know,
maybe talk about what happened, you know, in
Canada, huh?
What are you talking about? What happened in
Canada, right?
And remember when you came into my trailer
and you said all that weird stuff, but it
was like kind of cool because it was coming
from you. But like, in retrospect, it was
actually super f***ed up and dark.
Do you remember that?
Pete I don't know what to say.
I wasn't in Canada.
I didn't. I've never met you before.
This is the first time I've ever met you.
You don't really get sucked. You were like.
You should get yourself sucked.
Whoa, whoa, Hold up. I don't know what's
going on with you. I know I don't know you.
I read about you. I know you a little f***ed
up. It might be spiraling out now, man.
You may need help. I think you should go get
some help.
F***. Sorry.
I, uh. I don't know what's going on anymore.
I've been all f***ed up, but I'm actually.
I'm getting help, so.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
Okay. You need help? We all need help.
Godspeed. Okay.
I wish you the best. Sayonara.
Yeah. Shalom. Yeah.
Shalom is funny because it's.
Hello and goodbye.
Yeah. Aloha.
Have a good set. Ray Romano.
Hey, hey, Hey, buddy.
Hey, Let's have a little talk, okay?
I got him.
Oh, Peter.
You know, I've been praying for you.
Sometimes in life, we feel that there's a
shadow following us.
And this darkness comes over us that could
turn into fear.
What if this darkness never goes away?
But only later do we realize that the shadow
is actually the hand of God guiding us and
protecting us.
See, God, He needed your dad up there.
He died on the 11th, right?
Three times 11 is 33.
Three. Father, Son, The Holy Ghost.
Right. Christ was 33 when he died.
Same age as your father.
Your dad is Jesus incarnate.
Okay. You are never alone, sir.
Your dad is. He's right here in this room.
He is.
You could say hello to him.
Say hello to your father.
Say hi. Don't be shy.
Hi, Dad.
Did you feel his presence?
Did you? I did.
What was he, six-three.
Full of muscle. Your dad?
He's right here.
Your dad was a hero.
He's here. He's a hero.
Do you understand?
I want to thank you for your service, sir.
And thank you for not letting those dirty
scumbag Talbanians win.
Hey, one more round of applause for John
Stewart.
Oh, my God, my boy.
Don't mention global warming.
You're very touchy. I'd like to thank my
friend John Stewart for being able to talk
about rising sea levels and somehow,
amazingly, turn it into hilarious shtick.
And now, ladies and gentlemen, I am
extremely happy to announce he's alive and
well. Please welcome Pete Davidson.
Yeah. Sorry about all that fake death
business.
Wu-tang.
Hi, guys.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thanks, Al and John Stewart.
It is awesome to be here for the
environment. And, uh.
The f*** is. Uh, there's a- I have a troll.
Hey, Father. It's uh been 20 years since my
last confession.
I'm not really sure if what I've done could
even really be forgiven.
No worry, my son.
There's nothing our father can't forgive.
There's nothing he hasn't heard.
Okay.
Well. It's actually pretty
nice.
Dr. Rossi?
Pete.
Uh, why are you at my home?
Are you. Are you?
What about bobbing me? What is this?
This is. This is inappropriate.
You're the f***ing Scatman.
It's you. Pete. I think you're having a
manic, paranoid episode and you're
projecting this onto me.
That's bullshit. How come the user had an LLC
agreement attached to this address?
How come he used it? Fine.
Yes. Bravo, Pete.
Bravo. You've caught me.
Congratulations. Light up your pipe,
Sherlock Holmes. Because this was just a
books. What is this?
Why do you have a glaive? Have you come to
kill me? What are you doing? Pete?
I don't know, man. I'm really f***ing
confused.
Why don't we go inside and have a little chat
about this free of charge?
Hey, would it be possible to just, I don't
know, buy one of the bears?
Are you one of those?
How much can I buy it for?
Guys never earned a f***ing thing in your
life. What the bears worth?
Nothing. The victory and excitement of
winning the bear. Priceless.
These bears. Have been in these rafters for
20 years.
20?
Come on, don't be a p****.
F*** it.
How's a G sound, huh?
G sounds great.
Let's go.
F***. Now we're f***ing talking.
Oh, sh*t. Oh, f***.
Forgot to spray the bottles down.
What? What?
Oh, my God.
What the f***? What?
The f***? What the f***?
Yo, how did they know I'd be here?
I don't know.
I used your fake name.
Tostito Jones.
They probably here for me.
I just shot my second episode of Blue
Bloods. Fame move fast.
It's your rat.
F***. F***ing rat.
Let's do this. Let's go.
No more pictures.
Oh, sh*t. Oh.
Sh*t. Hey, what's up, boys?
Welcome to Miami 305.
That's the area code. Y'all ready to get
crispy? Come on, let's go.
Who the f*** is that?
Over here. Here, here.
Over here. Get off me!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Take that.
Take that. Yes.
Let's go. Let's go.
Are you
okay? You're bleeding.
Do you need a minute?
No. I'm gonna destroy that b*tch.
Come back. Let's go.
Come on.
I'm in. Come on.
Boo
! This why I do this.
This is why I do this. Good job, ladies.
Let's go.